Melanie's anona joins us she's a
congressional reporter and huddle author
at Politico Melanie good morning hi good
morning
I want to talk about Paula Reid story
for a minute here what is the intention
the motivation behind this is it just to
throw a ton of information in the
direction of Congress and the American
people or what what's the real deal here
well conservatives have been pushing for
this for months
Trump actually initially said last fall
that he wasn't gonna do this but they
say they need to be transparent with the
American people about the origins of the
Russia investigation the concern though
from Democrats is that William Barr is
just going to essentially be doing the
bidding of the president that he's going
to be chairing picking information he's
going to be weaponizing it that he could
release it sort of strategically heading
up to the 2020 election so there's not a
little there's not a lot of confidence
right now Democrats that he's going to
be sort of not political in the way he
goes about this one of the things we
know Democrats want to see is robert
muller to testify any indication whether
or not we'll see this in the near future
that is the million-dollar question
right now
chairman Jerry Nadler just said last
week that Muller is willing to testify
but in private he does not want to be a
political pawn in this fight but he is
willing to do an opening statement
publicly have a transcript made
available but Democrats think it's
really really important that the
American people hear from him publicly
his words will have more power than just
reading it so we're seeing this little
back forth here and of course the other
question is whether President Trump is
going to block him fortifying well he
could theoretically give an interview in
some other forum and the president
couldn't block that correct that's right
so I think that's a lot of the debate
right now the question is are Democrats
willing to have him in a closed-door
setting versus the public you've also
heard some Democrats start to grow a
little restless and float the idea of a
subpoena for Muller but that would be a
more drastic option so you know it's
still in the early stages we can we talk
about the president's relationship with
Nancy Pelosi which seem to reach a new
level this week there there had been
this sort of a grudging respect of the
president towards Nancy Pelosi but but
that that seemed to go out the door this
week with a single word yeah with a
single word what what has something
changed there you think I mean you're
absolutely right the president has long
held a lot of respect for Nancy Pelosi
as a
tition her ability to command respect in
her caucus but this week you did see
that turning-point and I think there's
two reasons number one he lost two key
court cases in this oversight battle
with Democrats that was really
frustrating for him it was a huge blow
to his stonewalling strategy and the
other thing is you're hearing more and
more Democrats start to call for
impeachment you also heard a Republican
last weekend Justin Amash of Michigan
become the first Republican to call for
this so he's really feeling the heat and
you're starting to see him lash out as a
result so Nancy Pelosi has been trying
to hold the line with some of the more
left-leaning people on her side of the
of the fence but but is she really going
to be able to do that I mean is it
enough well she bought herself a little
bit of time this past week she got her
troops together for closed-door
emergency meeting said we are making
progress we just won these court battles
we're gonna hold a contempt vote she
ramped up her own rhetoric but I think
there could be a tipping point in the
future especially if Trump does do
something like black Muller from
testifying or if he defies these court
orders you talk to these members on
Capitol Hill and they say okay we'll
follow the lead of Pelosi but there
could become a point where they can no
longer stay silent where they're gonna
have to get on that impeachment
bandwagon no shortage of things to talk
about this holiday weekend yet again
Melanie thank you very much Adam II